prepare the royal jet
[Music]
we are going back to america oh hell no
your majesty
first of all i know it took us three
decades but thank you thank you thank
you for making this movie
it's just like a feel like a gift that
we all needed after everything
but i have to talk to you eddie and
arsenio just
the cultural like impact of this movie
like across the diaspora you have
everyone from beyonce dressing up like
the characters from coming to america
you got
lupita nyong'o throwing birthday parties
i'm just curious what it's like to be a
part
of something like for a lot of black
people feels inherent in the sort of
like black experience and our cindy i'll
start with you
it's incredible i called eddie one day
and said yo i'm on la brea
in front of fat sals they've decorated
the building
for halloween as mcdowell's and there's
a line around the block for a sexual
chocolate shake
the movie wouldn't go away the culture
just kept it around
and if you we didn't plan on this we
always thought there would never be a
coming to america sequel
and one day while i'm getting coffee
eddie texted me and says
i got a script i think you should read
for coming to america and
the rest is history
making it the process was about a
five-year process
from the time i got the idea to when we
got the writers together and got the
script we worked on the script for it
might have been five or six different
versions of the script
but uh it was it took about four or five
years and we never ever ever thought
that we'd be
doing it it kind of happened like he
said because the movie was
became part of the culture and they have
these parties
and vh1 showed it 24 hours straight in
the end
yeah my mother would not let me watch
r-rated movies except for yours
eddie murphy movies gotta pass something
for america
should not be r-rated movies only one
thing in the movie where uh the woman
comes here the royal penis is clean and
when i go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you and other
than that there's it's totally
now this movie has nothing like this
movie
all black casts there's no profanity
there's no uh this it's not about civil
unrest or social injustice
there's no drama there's no one here
there's no there's nobody looking to the
camera screaming
wake up it's nice no none of that stuff
it's just
it's a it's a modern day uh fairy tale
that's that's about family and love
and tradition and doing the right thing
and it's
i'm glad you said the family part of it
because this movie has so much heart
people are going to be
completely disarmed by just how much it
makes you want to like hug your uncle
hug your auntie hug everybody in your
family and
i'm just curious though for y'all like
coming back
with the family you got to sign up for
the makeup again have they made it to
where you're in the chair a shorter
amount of time or were you like i didn't
want to do this
i'll start with your city you know it's
not a shorter amount of time but some of
the chemicals
are less abrasive now they have a better
glue removal process
but you still wake up the next day with
little brown boogers all over your bed
because that stuff never totally comes
off
what about you eddie did you find it
better this time you've been doing it
pretty consistently let's be honest
and uh it's no it's not any easy to do
it is still a five or six hour process
doing those makeups
and and there was one time on this movie
where i actually saw arsenio cry
he cried for real like when he hit the
end because it took two hours to take
off that makeup as
a baba the the witch doctor and uh one
night we
it was like 4 30 in the morning and
everybody was leaving for the day
and arsenio was still in the makeup
chair and
and he had a tissue and he had he said
that his eye was watering from the it
was like
he was crying oh
i feel your pain sir after a long day
and you just want to go home and like
i i feel that experience um
it's the contact lenses
crying bruh but it really is
it really is a hard work doing this
this is such a funny and incredible
movie
you guys should be so proud but the
general let's just say
he's giving it to akeem you're kind of
you're kind of taking him to
task for most of this movie well because
next dorians are more manly than the
ones in zamunda
and it's unfortunate for the moon the
ends
they should become more extraordinary
the more necessary and blood they have
the more manly and more powerful they
will be
so it's the charity of this the benefit
of the munda
yeah i mean yeah so the whole premise of
it is that your country is very much
trying to
uh negotiate with the moon to be a
marriage and it goes one way or the
other but
i have to say like this character you've
done some amazing characters obviously
with blade and there's been so many ones
where they're just iconic but
the hair of the general that's like a
whole thing talk about
because i know you guys wanted it to be
very animal inspired correct
yes yes you know like the ridgeback like
rhodesian ridgeback
or you see some of the animals in africa
that have ridges that run across their
head
yeah because they are tough like the
alligator or the crocodile
yeah i mean and you make an
entrance in the first part of the movie
for anybody to repeat on the outside see
that's important too all the copycats
out there it's going to be hard you guys
are going to figure out how we did that
one
this is true because i've already heard
people saying how the new costumes from
this one
are going to be like this year's hot
halloween one i guess they better get
started now figuring out how to do that
hair but
it wasn't just it's going to take you
that long too from now to halloween
october to get it right
not even the hair that's its own project
but the clothes that ruthie carter did
just because you were spending a lot of
it in like what would you say like
military attire
she swagged y'all out too like there was
some real
flyness to the whole general's vibe
next door is turned up victoria knows
how to turn it up
yeah we turn it up
i'm with that and actually i want to ask
you this just real quick because there's
a very big difference between
uh zumunda and next doria but i'm just
curious
what is the like bop in nextoria like
who are they listening to
like because i know you're a very big
music aficionado so
well you know the next door yeah we we
we we play
field feel like and then we play
you know james brown and we you know we
play parliament funkadelic
and pdd and puff daddy and and biggie
biggie smalls
yeah we always play biggie smalls yeah
they're in new york yeah yeah they're
still new york which i think is such a
huge part of this movie
um other thing the other thing i want to
talk about is again just like
how this movie has transcended things it
means so much to people i've you know
told people i was doing this
and they were just like so jealous just
because i was gonna get to see it and
they're they're very anxiously waiting
march 5th
but i'm just curious what was the
experience for you because you were
already
a working actor in hollywood at that
time so like it was different for you
this was part of your community doing
something
really big uh this film or the first
first the first one the first one yeah
just the first one like your
relationship to it being
in hollywood yeah i wanted to be in that
movie and a lot of my
my my acting classmates and my dance
classmates and street dancing
they were all in the movie i was wow i
was so jealous and wanted to be in that
movie
man and actually my minor in college was
african diasporic studies so
the the liberal arts was one focus but
all of my
out of um primary um
school focus was african studies so for
me
i was mr africa how could i not
be in the movie and let's just say it
you know
i know that you were one of the driving
forces of like when they were very first
talking about doing
a black panther movie like way back in
96 and i think that's one of the reasons
why we got you and blade right
was because you were going to bring that
i
still i want to i want to think about
you in black panther i'm just always
going to like
visualize that i don't know right yeah i
would do that quick
yeah yeah just because you know it was
some what they've done with it you know
and wonderfully is uh a reflection of
our vision at the time we didn't have
the tools
you know even the mindset the cultural
mindset
you know far as the white community was
concerned everything that you
associated with black panthers had to do
with revolutionaries and guns
you know um but now and what they've
accomplished and the tools that are
available
oh man absolutely
incredible just to think about you
may be popping up in black panther too
i'm just saying
kevin feige alright i don't care i can
do
western i can do irish i can do
spanish i could be a colombian puerto
rican
what you need what you need man i love
it
put it across the diaspora i love love
love this idea
you know yes i definitely want to talk
to you about the filming because
you guys got to have basically the
biggest
and best black party i've ever seen like
the finale of the movie is incredible
and everybody is there so i just want
you to tell us
what it was like for you that night
because i mean like not to spoil
anything but there's some big names that
show up in that big party
so fun so joyful and you know even
though we knew each other some of us
outside of the business
outside of work we had never worked with
each other
so the added uh um
gift of being on the job
at the same time with friends people you
admire
super talented people and it's being
preserved for eternity
oh man that's awesome get the whale
these crazy beautiful costumes and stuff
what that's it that's right there you go
let me hear you say hey ho
hey ho
no not to his mother tracy so great to
speak with you again
what's up listen
i'm feeling all right to talk to you
about this movie honestly yeah a long
time jay
you been waiting like me come on
well i mean that's the thing it's like
the question what makes you sign up
with your friends did you like it i
loved it i thought it was hilarious and
that's what i want to know though like
is it playing with eddie that makes you
like i gotta come back or the fact that
this is just coming to america and this
is like the blackest movie on the planet
it's it's a it's a fairy tale for us
it's a fairy tale for us and when i was
working with eddie on that set
it was a fairy tale for me to share
screen time with one of my comedic
heroes so then i had to snap out of it
and go to work
and i was i was his son's uncle his
great uncle too the funny uncle okay
and my job with my nephew was to let my
nephew know
never forget where you come from
that's why he had to come back to queens
to get me because he knew
i was the only one that could bring him
back stay who you are
i live it all the way through it that's
the new york thing i wanted to be
i wanted to be known i raised that boy
and if they don't think you good enough
in zumunda then later for him
tell him but he's just like father he's
just
his father well that's the other thing i
was going to ask you about too is that
is yeah that's your sister but this
movie is really new york
like that's the other thing about coming
to america there's just this entire like
new york vibe from it having like you
and eddie and
legends from that from that new york i'm
sure that was a special moment as well
yeah man i mean everyone not just eddie
and arsenio but evil leslie and
jermaine and all of those everyone
involved wesley
everyone everyone it was just an honor
to be there
and to be you know when i was there i'm
standing in front of mount rushmore
looking at mount rushmore
imagine a little human being standing in
front of this mountain
i mean that's the other thing with
comedians y'all are all part of this
like brotherhood where you all have gone
through the same thing you and eddie
being snl
you know such like great representation
on that show but this may be the first
time when we've gotten
so many of them together i mean was that
even
you know it's not all funny
it has a heart all of eddie movies have
heart
that's like busting loose with cicely
tyson and richard pryor
it had a heart when you look at the last
og it has a heart absolutely
i'll just say that was the first time i
got to talk to you is for the last so
gee and this
it feels very similar in that because it
again you bring in
the best people but let me just ask you
though
the costumes y'all got ruthie carter on
this one
like i'm guessing there's something you
wanted to cough right you want to take
it home
she is roof to meet her to take pictures
with her
the [ __ ] oxygen with her i love that
woman i love that lady
she's the og she's she's the the yoda
she's the the obi-wan kenobi in the
universe of that
anything you wanted to steal from
somebody else's costume or from one of
yours
no no no no i didn't want to see that
just being a part of the movie
i would have stole it me personally i'm
sorry they would have had to lock it
down
there's no way i'm not walking out with
something i have the script i have the
original script that i was given and
that's enough for me
oh that's so great the original script
for for
the original yeah oh that is so
incredible all right so another thing
with you guys
you're right it's not all slapstick
there's heart there's a lot of family in
this like this
feels like that and so i was just
curious
which one of y'all is the one that
breaks first though because y'all are ab
living and cracking jokes and at a
certain point
the fun but we also knew we had to get
through this movie
because there's three people on set it
was thousands on set
so we all had the discipline and
professionalism to know we would have
fun
but we had to you know there's a
director there
with all those people there and if we
didn't get through it it would just be
totally unprofessional
and you know this is eddie murphy yeah
you don't keep goofing around and stuff
like that
so well a little bit of goofy though
like
you and leslie y'all together yeah tons
of fun
tons of fun you said like you said
you're staring out at rap much more
there must be
and this was a like a shoot where you
know there were so many legends coming
through but is there one day
or one particular moment that's like you
know what you're gonna hold it in your
heart
from coming to america like one day
where you're just like this is nuts
yeah the day eddie asked me asked me to
be
in it that was the day tell me what he
did he called you up said let's do it
well let's do it and it was that quick
i guess for my last question for this
one talk about jermaine man because
you're right you basically had to make
him your your son in this so
talk about you guys sort of doing that
together it's funny as fast as
people he's a talent and i loved him and
right away we knew our connection he
knew i was his uncle and he was my
nephew
and i already ready right away i knew he
had that spirit
but he was going to do what he wanted to
do you see that in the opening scene
with me and him
yep it's from there i was our
relationship is established
right then and there i don't need no
handouts
wait a minute all right okay
first of all congratulations to both of
you for the film
it's hysterical and i'm guessing
probably one of the greatest calls when
eddie murphy says yeah we're gonna you
know basically take the number one movie
in the black experience and redo the
sequel you get to come along so jermaine
talk about that call
god damn jackie man
throw me yo thank you but it's it's
honestly it's an honor
it's an honor eddie is my idol uh plain
and simple my idol my hero
so to get that call was very validating
i've been doing this 15 years so to get
that call
felt like man i'm doing something right
and he likes my comedy and he likes me
as an actor
it meant a lot he's the reason why i'm
here and the reason why
um i get to do what i do so he's opened
so many doors for me
and actors like me so it's truly just a
blessing and um
i'm just i'm enjoying the ride yeah i
mean that's a great ride to be on and on
zombo like
i don't know like it's not obviously
jermaine with the comedian but
i just anybody if they called me up to
be an extra i'd be like yes
please i survived every extra had on
that set they were
sneaking pictures of eddie like they
were really like just it was like y'all
on the same movie yeah
it'll be evidence later you don't need a
you're making a movie you don't need a
picture what are you doing
well we needed that picture yeah i'm
living history
i mean i was i was in south africa back
home when i got the call
and i could not believe it i mean i
definitely cried
i will not front and act fresh yeah okay
i was like
but also just like what a beautiful
first paul soca moment it is for me
because it is my personal coming to
america story it's my first breakout
role
and it happens to be in coming to
america so it really is going to be um
fun premiering this film to the rest of
the world
and obviously we better be certified
fresh
hey look listen i in my heart you are
but i have no control over it as i tell
people i just get to be the mouthpiece
that tells everyone to see it because
this is the thing
it doesn't matter what the score is i
saw it people are gonna get to see it
and for so many of us that's like a huge
part of it because they just wanted this
movie to happen
for like 30 plus years yeah i'm curious
for you is from
the south african perspective because
this was wakanda
before black panther and there's just
something
aspirational great about that
presentation i'm just curious
how that resonated with you when you
first saw it i mean i love that you
you you take that reference because you
know it really was
the first imagination of what african
luxury and
crazy rich africans would look you know
what i mean
um so for me you know it's it's all
about family it's about the pursuit
of identity it's about purpose it's
about leaving behind what you know
and and going forth to to the unknown
you know and embracing that
but i think one of the most important
central themes as well is the female
empowerment
which is really really really fantastic
and i think
all the females that were given those
kinds of arcs truly carried those
stories
and a lot of women everywhere around the
world including the african continent
will watch feel seen feel heard and feel
represented
you know for me being in this character
and playing a traditional
zamundan woman is so fantastic
and so awesome because i knew that there
were certain nuances that i would
introduce from the continent
that you know only an african woman
could be able to kind of
you know truly embody and i really
really wanted to tell the story
and it's such an honor honestly it
really really is
yeah i mean and look at it it's dripping
with african
like the entire black experience across
the diaspora but particularly african
culture and that comes very much
courtesy
of ruthie carter's costumes y'all let's
talk about it
asked everyone this and no one has said
this but like
are you saying none of y'all wanted to
cop like a like a bracelet
was there an outfit that you were trying
to like ask ruthie please let me take
this one home or were you like no
girl look at my in my hands right now
now imagine this times 10. that's water
so i wanted every piece of jewelry she
knows it
i'm like this crowd who's the designer
ruth please help you know but i was just
saying that you know that woman
is an encyclopedia she is a historian
she is way way above even being called a
costume designer
she really really does give so much of
her mind
and and so much care in into into how
she
she portrays um imagery and and and
people
just using clothes and tells that story
so i'm i'm really happy for her
especially now that she's getting
a hollywood walk of fame she's going
she's the first woman ever
first designer ever i think
and we're saying it was way too long for
it to get there but what about you
jermaine those suits
are bad like let me just say in the best
way possible
in the 80s way let me say those were bad
i had just
i've never been more blown away by uh an
artist's work she's an artist
you know she treats us like a canvas and
we just let her do her thing
every piece was different it wasn't like
she was repeating pieces
every piece had its at a particular a
pattern that was unique to the
individual like especially from the
extras to to eddie like everybody had a
thing it was beautiful and she took
such you know care and like you know uh
patience with everything and she
deserves that walk of fame star like she
she definitely does um and but again she
loves what she does we talk to her she
has no ego about anything that she does
she's truly just a normal like amazing
woman who just
genuinely just is enthusiastic about
everything that she does and
i love her energy man i'd love to work
with her again i
out of respect i didn't steal any
clothes
see this is why i'm a journalist because
i know i would be fired from
the second job immediately because i'm
sorry i'm taking it i'm taking it with
me for you jermaine like this is kind of
i think you know you get eddie murphy
and leslie jones as your parents so
that's amazing
but then we're adding all of these other
ones i'm just curious who breaks the
take
who's the one that ruins the take out of
all those legends or did literally
everyone just have to button it up
like i don't know who was the one that
broke character in the most it was no
button it up i would say
leslie only because we had the we had
the most scenes together i believe
i'm in the most comedic ones so there
were times when like
one time leslie was trying to tell me
about the song called push push in the
bush
and i've never heard this song before
and she's like come on you heard the
song i'm like i've never heard push
pushing the button
you start singing it push push in the
bush i'm like i never heard the song so
she's dancing and singing
and i'm like i gotta go on set they call
us on set so we go on set
and i'm doing my lines i look up at
leslie who's doing her lines at me
off screen and she's sweating just
dripping sweat and i'm like
what what happened what do you say she
goes i'm sorry
i can't do it she couldn't do her lines
she was still
out of breath from the push bush in the
bush christmas in the bush
yeah and it's like it's what what in the
butt it must be like the parody version
of that i think so i have no idea but it
was an 80s song or whatever
and yeah it was that was just one of a
million times
leslie broke me and broke herself on on
camera so
she was she was an amazing like person
to be around and share those moments
i always thought that mika was going to
be queen a woman isn't allowed to lose
amunda it's the law
ladies first of all congratulations on
the film it is
incredible and it's so great that it's
coming back with a sequel because like
with so many of us we remember
the first time we saw this movie it's
like part of i feel like the black
american experience
but i'm just curious if you guys can
tell me when you first saw it and
bella i'm going to start with you
because i don't know like was it really
early that you got to see it
oh no i i mean kind of i was like 10 or
11 when i saw it for the first time
and what was that emotion like this is
not just dad made it but it's also like
the movie it was awesome that was the
first time i saw black royalty on screen
and then um being able to connect to it
because it's my dad
so it was even cooler and um just it was
really empowering to see at such a young
age
kylie go ahead um yeah um i watched it
um way before i got the audition for it
so i already knew what i was getting
into and
that even made me more excited um not
only if i haven't watched it i've heard
of it before
so i've seen it plenty of times and i
was so excited that i was
um going to be a part of the second the
sequel
because the first movie it's amazing
it's hilarious i love watching it
no it is it is a movie too where
everybody talks about not only how funny
it was
how new york it was how it was so
aspirational to see black royalty
but they also talk about the costumes
and this time around
y'all got ruthie carter which i
that's completely amazing she obviously
did the costumes as well for black
panther so
just curious did you fall in love with
any of the costumes that you got to see
bella was there anything you were trying
to like
nudge ruthie to be like if you want to
slip this in my trailer
um definitely there was this dress that
i was wearing and it was a yellow dress
and um from far away it looks like a
bunch of flowers but when you look close
you can see that it's the designer space
like not ruth's face but a designer that
she collaborated with
and uh it was just it was really cool
every single time i looked at all my
clothes i found different designs and i
was like oh
so beautiful and um we got a bird's eye
shot
on the yellow dress and uh what was
really cool about it is
i was twirling and it was going out so
it looked really pretty with the
bird's eye shot that we got but um i
didn't take anything
i know it's not like you'd be able to
probably get away with it your dad might
like
peep your closet and be like wait a
minute
[Laughter]
looks like it's from set it's like no
it's not
i mean he is a producer on this film so
i could see him maybe taking the dad hat
off to be like hey
[Laughter]
kylie what about you again costumes
are incredible was there any either from
the original or this one that you're
like
that's that's fashion goals yeah um i
have
two favorites actually i've mentioned my
bubble gum dress
um it has this poncho type thing over it
and um
i'm so weird on set i used to like pull
my hands in when i get cold and i'd like
hide my arms
and bella would be like where'd your
hands go and i'm like it disappeared
yeah she literally just walk around and
like a gum drop
my god that is so first of all folks
need to see the movie so they can put
this together visually in their mind but
that is adorable
and i'm sure like the entire crew was
just like awing
every time you walk by looking like that
all bundled up
um bella i have to ask you too because
again you kind of got a bird's eye view
of this
movie's effect and i'm sure it was
probably you
that was like telling your dad hey all
the people from black panther
just redid coming to america as part of
like the party that lupita nyong'o does
for her birthday you know she gets all
up in the costumes
so i'm just curious like the cultural
impact of it
like the fact that people are still like
doing the costumes and they're doing
mcdowell's impersonations and like
people
throw parties around it i'm just
wondering what that means for you
personally to see
how your dad had this effect on again
the black culture
in america it's really cool i think i
saw
pictures of beyonce dressed up one time
and i was like
oh my god the queen but um
no yeah it's really cool to see the
impact that he had and very
um inspirational for me because you know
he's my father so being able to see him
uh
impact all these people um even at such
a young age
definitely made me feel like i could do
that too when i got older so
i'm very thankful for that and just for
him because
he's a cool cool dude he's a cool guy
yeah
i mean i'm just gonna go ahead and say
it you definitely have the like if
you're somebody's like oh i got a cool
dad
you went that's a mic drop every time
for you so
we own it on that one i found out the
other day
save it again he invented the mic drop
the other day i found out
yeah okay he was literally like
he he gave birth to the the thing that
literally
yeah it's a part of the vernacular so
many more things too
um kylie um i'm gonna ask you about this
one because
there's so many comedians in this movie
and they are literally some of the
legends of comedy not just eddie arsenio
leslie jermaine's hysterical tracy's
hysterical and then so many of the cast
members who are just actors are also
very funny
did you who was the hardest one for you
to be around and keep a straight face
like who was the one where you're like
i really gotta work hard not to giggle
yes um you know when everybody is in the
same room
especially when people like arsenio hall
eddie murphy was wesley snipes when
they'd all be in the same room
it's hard to not explode because they're
all so
funny individually wesley snipes he's
hilarious so is
eddie murphy and arsenio hall when
they're all in the same room you just
see
like this connection and you're trying
so hard not to explode inside you're
like stay calm deep breaths
and you know when they crack a joke
every time inside i'm like
don't laugh and when that director yells
cut i would just explode along with
bella i was gonna say bella are you do
you feel numb to it because there's been
comedians in and out of your sphere
probably for as long as you can remember
i mean there's such a brotherhood
between comedians already
were you practiced with not laughing or
did that actually make it worse because
some of these people you've been seeing
again since you were little
well i feel like
um i never get used to it because it's
always funny to me
but um i feel like i don't know
i it was hard not to break during those
scenes kind of what
kylie's saying and um it was just it
it was difficult very funny
like what did they do for an audition
for you did they make you like
impersonate your dad like
what do they like see if you can do the
eddie murphy laugh like is that even an
audition that would have been so weird
but um didn't you even do it can you do
the laugh i doubt it but i mean just
what do you mean that's not how he
laughs i think it's so funny when people
do that as an impression because i'm
like that's not it but okay
but i can't even do it
but um very good very good thank you
but they uh originally i asked to be an
extra on the film because i didn't think
i was even going to be in the movie at
all
because we're not allowed to work until
we're 18 in this industry
specifically so um i didn't think i was
going to be in it and then
you know i did i do scenes with my dad
all the time we watch movies all the
time
you know i was going to acting classes i
was doing my plays here and there
and i think he just saw that and was
like why don't you audition for the
princess if you want
and i was like i want to you know
so i went out for it and it was awesome
it was really cool
[Music]
they ain't gonna sharpen you too nephew
now it's coming to me